the board of the National Organization
for Women and the author of the myth of
male power and why men are the way they
are next he defends the pay gap and his
new book why men earned more this talk
from the Cato Institute in Washington DC
is an hour and 15 minutes i'm looking at
into this audience and only a fraction
of you have heard me speak before but
those of you who do know what's going to
be coming next which is that i never
give a speech in the normal way of
speech giving i always do something
interactive with the audience and so i'm
going to be asking you to work with me
today because you'll get a lot more out
of this presentation as you as you
actually experience some of the things
i'll be talking about i'm going to ask
all of the men to sit over on this side
and all of the women to sit over on this
side and we'll be doing something
interactive that will allow us to see
the results in relation to a pay gap
much more easily so in case you forgot
who you are it's been over here and
women over here okay no I'm being
serious this is just poor yes yo yo hey
so be a lot of fun
he
this a young woman would like somebody
up front with her she's all right
nothing that's only intellectual can
really be fully experience so well okay
the folk one of the themes of why men
are more is that there is it in three
years of researching this issue yes I
was thank you very much testing is that
working no do you know okay great I'm
glad we have a technological person
that's Maria okay
so that's that is working
are you working with me is it yes is
there a woman here that can fix jus
there's something technologically here
with this okay okay what I found was
that there are 25 differences between
what men and women do in the workplace
that each of those differences on
average lead to men earning more money
but each of those differences also lead
to women having better lives so the you
know once again the women have
outsmarted us so the book therefore does
not suggest that women should do each of
these things because I obviously want
women I have two daughters I want women
to have better lives and men to have
better lives but it is it suggests that
there are 25 significant decisions that
when all those decisions are controlled
for that men today actually earn less
money than women do for the same work
they earn more money than women do for
25 different types of decisions at work
but obviously those decisions allow for
a roadmap to be created for any woman
who wants to earn more money but that
going through each of those decisions
she can she can find 25 different ways
turn more money than the average man
should she wish to however each of those
decisions come with trade-offs when you
when you move quickly when you work
extra hours often times you don't enjoy
it as much when you work in certain
feels like hazardous occupations most
people don't enjoy dying as much and so
the the outcome of doing these these
things that earn more money do not
necessarily lead to a better life so I
looked so I interview top women who have
succeeded in the world in terms of
financial success and I say to them if
you were to talk to your granddaughter
and advise her as to what you would do
over again what would you do differently
what would you do the same i always say
granddaughter because your children
never listen so so now i'm going to ask
us though to test out this thesis in our
own lives right here in the room so i'm
going to ask you to do two things i'm
going to ask you to stand up if you fit
a certain description i'm going to ask
you to look around and get a sense as to
whether there are more men
than women standing up and I'm going to
be asking you to count the number of
times that you stand up so keep track of
the number of times that you stand up so
at the end I'll be asking for some some
calculations so we can see right here in
this room the different decisions or the
similar decisions that men and women
make so I'm going to ask you to stand up
if you work in a field of technology or
the hard sciences such as pharmacology
or hard sciences or in computer sciences
or engineering so stand up if you work
in one of those fields okay we have
maybe seven men and no women in this
room working in technology the hard
sciences each of these each of these are
decisions that men versus women make and
each time you stand up those are one of
the indicators of what leads to hype a
second stand up if you are working in a
field that is hazardous for at least two
or have worked in a field that is
hazardous for at least two or more years
of your life stand up okay there are two
men that have done that and two women
we're even on that hazardous pay very
good stand up if you work in a field
that exposed you to the wind the rain
and the snow what I call an exposure
profession for at least two years of
your life stand up if you've done that
there are about four six nine men and
two women stand up if you have work in a
field in which you cannot
psychologically check out at the end of
the day so for example a corporate
attorney can't usually try to check out
at the end of the day a librarian
usually can check out at the end of the
day stand up if you work in a field in
which you cannot check out at the end of
the day okay we have about sixty percent
of the men and about forty percent of
the women moving up to forty five
percent of the women okay thank you
stand up if you work in a field that is
less fulfilling than a field in which
you would choose to work in
had you won the lottery stand up if you
work in a field that is less fulfilling
than a field you would choose to work in
had you won the lottery that's about
eighty percent of the men and about
fifteen percent of the women stand up if
you work in a field requiring you to
take considerable financial and
emotional risks such as a venture
capitalist as a salesperson versus an
investment banker or a bank teller stand
up if you work in a field requiring you
to take considerable financial and
emotional risks interesting small
percentage of people I would expect the
de Cato Institute would have attracted a
higher percentage of that 246 people
working in fields that attract financial
have financial and emotional risk being
serious all males no females okay oh I'm
sorry I look right past you my apologies
and what exactly and speaking up after
that too I applaud you stand up if you
work in a field in which you work the
worst shifts during the worst hours so
for example if you're a private practice
md and you work the shifts late late
shifts or during the night or if you
work in a factory and work shifts like
from Midnight's of five six seven in the
morning stand up if you work the worst
shifts during the worst hours okay one
person oh yeah yes exactly hardly
representative America yeah but but
within even within the framework of
thank you two women I'm doing that even
within the framework of this we can see
a significant male-female difference
obviously stand up if you work in a
field that requires constant updating
friends for example an engineer versus
say a french-language scholar
about 80 ohm about ninety-five percent
of the men and about fifty-five sixty
percent of the women okay stand up stand
up if you work in a subfield that has
even more of these nine characteristics
so for example if you're a nurse but
your sub field is a nurse anesthetist
you would have a lot of these other nine
characteristics that i mentioned working
in technology working maybe tough hour
is that type of thing or if you're a
cardiac if you're a doctor but you're a
cardiac surgeon you'd have a lot of
those characteristics of working in
technical fields may not be fulfilling
because you're working with death or
dying versus a psychiatrist working in a
field is more fulfilling comparatively
so stand up if your sub field increases
some of the things I just talked about
like working even longer hours working
in more more tougher risks or whatever
set up if your sub field increases the
things I've just been talking about
stand up only your sub field like say
your nurse anesthetist as opposed to
just a nurse or say you're a doctor but
your cardiac surgeon would be your sub
field okay okay almost nobody fits in
that category I'll stand up if you work
more than 40 hours a week stand up if
you work more than 40 hours a week okay
here we have about eighty percent of the
men and about 65 seventy percent of the
women now stand up if you work more than
60 hours a week 60 hours a week we have
we're down to about nine men and three
women as I can't thank you stand up if
you have more than 20 years experience
in your current occupation 20 years
experience in your current occupation
okay there you can get about 14 men and
about four women stand up if you have
more than 10 years of an interrupted
with your current employer this is to
caveat to two differences from the
former one on interrupted experience and
with your current employer stand up okay
we have about 15 men and about three
women stand up if you worked 51 or 52
weeks last year that is you if you took
two weeks of vacation you're not in this
group so stand up if you work 51 or 52
weeks last year so this is what I stand
up if you're crazy okay so we're about
even on that issue there okay stand up
if you were absent less than two days
last year stand up you if you were
absent less than two days last year it's
about eight men and two women okay stand
up if you commute more than 25 miles
round trip to work each day if you
commute more than 25 miles round trip
that's round trip commute to work each
day 2 4 6 8 10 11 men and two four or
five women okay stand up if you live in
a city you do not wish to live in
because you are needed there by your
employer send a few set up if you live
in a city yeah you did not wish to live
in because you are needed there by her
employer about four men and about two
women stand up if you travel more than
five days per month on your job stand up
if you travel more than five days per
month on your job well we only have two
insane people in this room
except for me three stand up if you are
a VP or above working at a bottom line
position contributing directly to your
company's profits and losses for example
sales marketing invested in financial
management I'll repeat that stand up if
you were a VP or above vice president
above working in a bottom line position
contributing directly to your company's
profits and losses sales marketing
invested in financial management stand
up it's washing only earlier and then
company right yes well I'm very good TJ
very good yeah stand up if you are with
a company or organization with more than
a thousand employees and your
responsibility is national that is
nationwide for all your employees like a
national buyer at Nordstrom's versus a
local buyer okay we have two women and
two men that wait is it three three men
and two women okay and stand up if you
are paid on commission I know this is
Washington nobody one person who's a
woman and one who's a man okay so okay
what I've just gone over is 21 of the 25
measurable differences between men and
women how many of you did in fact
remember to keep track of the number of
times you stood up okay only about a
quarter of the audience did keep track
of that then do the best that you can to
estimate how many rate stood up at least
ten times raise your hand if you stood
up you think about ten times or more and
how many stood up ten times our viewer
well obviously everybody else by
definition good question words how many
people sit up at least six times hey
about
seventy-five percent of the men and
about fifteen percent of the women so we
get even in the in the in the context of
this room a great deal the differences
between men and women when you're out in
the in Middle America where there is a
greater percentage of people working in
corporations and companies you see a
great deal of difference particularly in
the areas of the choices of fields the
choices of fields are the fields that
earn the most are clearly engineering
and computer sciences and yet the and
women in those fields and every single
one of those fields with just a couple
of exceptions in the subfields of
engineering and the subfields of
computer sciences earn more than men do
so one of the things that I discovered
as an even without the other issue
things like greater commutes do it doing
work in the hazardous aspects of those
fields like people who are in hazard
hazardous fields are much much more
likely to be men as you know 93% of
people who died at work are men so even
so if you have a technical field in a
hazardous field the chances of man
working in that are much greater in each
of these areas there's a certain
percentage increase that normally occurs
if you increase your involvement in
those fields so for example if a person
works puts in more hours per week the
average person who puts in more hours
per week if they put in 44 hours a week
what would be your guess as to how much
more they make than a person putting in
34 hours a week 44 verses 34 will be
your guest fifty percent more than ten
percent more twenty percent more anybody
else fifty percent more is close to a
hundred percent more now the
implications of that are enormous the
average male works three hours the
average full-time working male works
three hours more per week than the
average full-time working female that
alone accounts for seventy percent of
the pay gap difference but looked at in
terms of opportunities for women and
firm end if a person who works 44 hours
a week makes almost twice as much as a
person working 34 hours a week not
usually at the same job of course but a
person working
44 hours a week usually is able to
leverage that extra commitment into
getting different types of jobs working
with different types of companies that
want the person with greater amounts of
flexibility look at what that implies
for family decisions a child a child is
about ready to come into a family that
doesn't have children and we usually
make a decision of as to the woman
usually makes one of three decisions she
either decides to work full-time be
full-time involved with the children or
do some combination of both the men
makes three decisions also he decides to
work two full time or to work full-time
or to work full-time and so they usually
generate among those three options and
so the women who but but one option
that's available when we know that you
earn almost twice as much by working
forty four verses 34 hours a week is
that the woman who is career oriented go
out and be full-time involved with her
career if she has children that her
husband's stay home focus on his career
be sorry focus on the family focus on
moving torte with the woman's career
supporting the woman but that means of
course a tremendous difference in the
way we socialize men and women it means
that when we socialize women who are
interested in being high-powered women
that the women make the automatic
assumption that she will marry a
high-powered man she can marry a
high-powered man and it can work out if
she is and he are not going to have any
children but if she's going to have
children and and he's going to have
children then usually the combination of
family and work does better she ends up
happier if she's with a man who is
focused on raising those children rather
than a nanny being the one that raises
the children the children grow up more
effectively single fathers do do a
decent single fathers do a very good job
raising children and fathers who are
stay-at-home dads do a very good job
raising children in both cases the
children turn out better than when the
reverse is the case and so the on 26
different areas of measurement so we
have lots of options to run the world
our decision-making in the family
differently the most important single
decision that one makes aside from these
25 decisions are actually not any one of
these 25 decisions the most important
single
your decision that I found is the choice
of a spouse know is if you want to
figure out what you want to do with your
life in terms of balancing career and
family the person you choose as your
partner is the most important single
decision you make in that regard be
happy I sort of entertain more on that
later but I want to move on to some of
the other things that are needed to be
considered so the focus of my research
was looking at these 25 differences
looking at the discrimination that still
remains against women in the workplace
looking at the discrimination that is
never looked at that is against men in
the workplace looking at the power of
women and men to attract money that is
not workplace derived such as what i
call genetic celebrity power the ability
of a beautiful woman to attract income
in a lot of different ways that is not
available for for most men in the world
and so those were some of the sort of
foci of that what I what got me into all
of this research was when I was on the
board of now in New York City I was I
was which I was on for three years I
used to wear the 59 sent pin most of you
are too young to remember what that 59 s
head pin was about but for those of us
aged people that was a pin we used to
wear that suggested that men earned a
dollar for each 59 cents that women were
made in the workplace and we all believe
that the the gap between that dollar in
that 59 cents was discrimination against
women and I was one of the people who
very strongly believe that and protested
against that discrimination but one day
I sort of asked myself a question that
sort of got me into the type of trouble
that Larry Summers got into it Harvard I
asked myself this question I said if men
paid if men got paid a dollar for each
59 cents that women got paid for the
same work why would anybody hire a man
and then I asked I pressed myself a
little bit further on that issue and I
said well I'm just going to go out and
form an all-female firm because
obviously then I can produce things for
59 cents that other firms have to sell
for a dollar but I figured that maybe
somebody thought of that before me
I started asking maybe there's something
else to the whole situation besides that
because clearly as I thought more
carefully about it if a company did hire
all men and it cost them a dollar and
other companies hired all women in a
cost them 59 cents to produce the same
brought up that capitalism has built
into it a punishment for people who are
stupid enough to discriminate if you're
stupid enough to discriminate and hire
the man when the women can produce it
the same product for about half that
amount you're going to be soon losing
business and the punishment will be
being put out of business or going broke
and so that in a way the government
wasn't necessarily needed perhaps I
asked myself to do what was already
built into the structure of capitalism
which was to punish people who
discriminated whoo-hoo-hoo and who
exercised that discrimination in terms
of hiring people who were less
productive for the same work and paying
them more money so I started thinking
about that and then I said well then
maybe if that's the case there may be
what other factors are involved that
separate out men's work from women the
work that the decisions that men make
versus the decisions that women make and
could they account for the pay gap so as
I started looking at that I'm realizing
that there is three that men work more
than three hours more than women and in
the workplace I realize as I'm seeing
that accounted for seventy percent of
the pay gap I started looking at each of
these other issues and seeing that even
10 15 years ago we had very interesting
data about men and women that no one has
ever heard of so for example or very few
people have ever heard of one example
was I started looking at the differences
between never married women and never
married men it made sense to me that if
it wasn't gender discrimination that
maybe never married men and never
married women would earn more similar
amounts to each other if it was about
decisions of our own family that was
creating difference as an outcome so I
went back to Jesse Bernards book future
of marriage written 30 some-odd years
ago found in an appendix to that
fact that never married women earned
more than never married men never
married women 30 years ago earned more
than never married men so I was
wondering if that still was the same and
and then some of my feminist colleagues
rightly and accurately said to me Warren
the reason that never married women
maybe do earn more than never married
men is because let's face it never
married women are winners and never
married men are losers that and well
while losers and winners are pretty is a
pretty tough way of putting it what was
true about what my feminist colleagues
told me was that never married women did
tend to work more hours per week then
never married men and never married
women on average were more educated than
never married men so I controlled for
education and I controlled for hours
worked and i found that today men who
are never marry follow all this year men
who are never married and never had
children earn eighty-five percent of
what women earn who are never married
and have never had children when
education is controlled for when income
is controlled for and age is controlled
for so I suddenly had a new way of
looking at the workplace so I said if
that's the case then there should be a
number of fields in which women may be
out earned men even as a whole as a rule
and found in fact that there were more
than 90 fields in which women outer and
men and that started getting me thinking
of something different if there are 90
fields in which women outturn men and
all the newspaper discussions and media
discussions was folk we're focusing on
women as being discriminated
discriminated against we were putting
our binoculars on the areas of
discrimination against women and we were
missing tremendous opportunities for
women and so we started looking at and
putting my binoculars on opportunities
for women and not only did I find there
were 90 fields in which women outer and
men but I also found that there were 39
very large fields in which women outer
in
by at least five percent I started
seeing that there were feels like they
were and I discovered many other things
in those fields I filed out the
pharmacist are now earning more than
medical doctors because of HMOs lowering
the amount of income that medical
doctors were making so I started looking
at fields that were user-friendly two
women that fits some of these categories
of women usually decide to choose for
found that investment bankers who are
females not only do extremely well but
they significantly outturn male
investment bankers found that the dental
hygiene hygienists will be one of the
few what are the really major growing
fields and the next 10 to 12 years and
dental hygienists is one of those fields
that well think about it raise your hand
if you would like you if you would
prefer a man's fingers in your mouth to
a woman's fingers in your mouth raise
your hand if you prefer a woman's
fingers in your mouth to a man's fingers
in your mouth the common denominator is
your hands come on it really either way
if you and the great majority of people
do prefer woman's fingers in your mouth
whether they are a woman or a man and if
you think about how many of you have had
dental hygienists who were men just two
people in the room how many of you have
had dental hygienist who are women and
so what what we realized is there a lot
of fields particularly feels that
involved touching people or looking at
people naked from both sexes that
completely discriminated against men a
man who wants and I so I asked my
dentist about this and I said you know
would you hire a male dental hygienists
and he looked at me he knows what I
write about and he smiled and he said
actually I did have a male who's a
dental hygienist ten percent of people
who get dental hygienist training or men
he said I did have a man just the other
day who called me who was a dental
hygienist I said okay what did you tell
him i said sorry i said was that because
you had no openings i said no it's
because I my customers will not want a
man being a dental hygienist and you
know in a lot of areas like this think
of
a massage would you rather have raised
your hand if you'd prefer to have a
massage by a man okay some of them raise
your head if you'd prefer to have a
massage by a woman as a rule of massage
therapists fine that they if they're a
man they have a much harder time getting
a job as a massage therapist or being
used as often think about OBGYNs 20 30
years ago when before the Boston woman
its health collective started helping
women understand the value of people
attending to you in a different way we
had almost all OB gyns were males but
today almost all of our OB gyns are
females but it goes in a much more
subtle type of way and if we go to
walmart and we here now one and a half
million people are suing walmart for
discrimination against women but when i
started looking at more carefully at the
lawsuits case i found that in all the in
all the departments of walmart in which
there is no skills needed like they're
not an auto mechanic not maintenance or
no physical labor required like security
or risking of life and all those
departments the people who were hired
mostly were which sex women so women's
apparel ninety-nine percent women men's
apparel ninety-three percent what women
and every single Department of Walmart
the there were ninety percent or more
women when no skills were required so
what then happens is that you then have
people because of this discrimination
against men it forces men to get skills
in order to be hired having gotten
skills in order to be hired those skills
are able to be leveraged to be promoted
more quickly and so you then have what
appears to be discrimination against
women when in fact the initial
discrimination is very clearly against
men at walmart or in many other areas of
the country we see this in elementary
school teaching it is very difficult to
ask any friend of yours that has a
degree in elementary school teaching
who's a
for a job with the fear of male
sexuality there's a great deal of fear
of hiring men as nursery school teachers
or discrimination against women you
could understand it but it's still a
form of discrimination and so there's so
and and the difficulty is that our
children don't have especially children
in urban areas that are more likely to
grow up and especially poor urban areas
that are more likely to grow up in
female only households they go from
female only households to female
dominated school systems and then we
wonder why they join gangs for the
purpose of having a male role model so a
lot needs to sort of be reconsidered
within that framework I started asking
myself the question because another
feminist objection that occurred that
came up to me constantly was Warren you
know it's not so much about supply and
demand male bosses can be so prejudiced
that they can that they can sort of
discriminate against women because they
just plain value women less than men so
I started asking myself the question ok
let's look then at companies in which
women were their own bosses which women
were self-employed at when I first
started the research on that and it
firms that women-owned women made twenty
nine percent of what men made that went
up to thirty five percent and today it's
at forty-nine percent so in other words
when women have male bosses or bosses
they're far more likely to earn much
more close to what men earn then when
women are their own bosses and the
reason for that is when we we look more
closely as self-employed women versus
self-employed men who own their own
businesses we find that the goals of
self-employed men and women are
different the goals of self employed
women are usually to have a balanced
life in which they can connect with
their children and still earn money the
goals of self-employed men are much more
likely to be money focus so it's not
that that's discrimination that's the
the issue and it's not that that this
should be any different it's that women
and men choose different foci in their
work and particularly we see this in the
in the self employment so then I got
another objection which was it well
maybe it's really part time women so I
looked at the 92 the 2004 data for
part-time women from the broad the raw
data from the US bureau of labor
statistics i found that part-time women
who earn one hundred ten percent of what
part time men are in working the same
number of hours part time so i tried to
cut the data each way as and look and
look carefully at each of the the
dimensions of that what I began to start
seeing if I were if this book had came
to start evolving and having one theme
is I began to start seeing that pay is
not about getting the power per se that
pay is about giving up the pow giving up
power to get the power of pay that is
each of the times that many of it used
to it up you stood up to do things
working more hours not choosing almost
every man here in the room said that you
would not choose to work in the field
you're working in if you won the lottery
so you mate you gave up one dream the
dream of doing what was most fulfilling
to get a different account thing
accomplished which was earning money and
so men as a rule have learned to define
power very differently than women women
have learned to define power largely
through the help of the women's movement
and since the women's movement as
figuring out how to have control of
their life how to becoming look inside
of themselves decide what their values
are decide how to become more of the
person that you would like to be in my
opinion that's the correct definition of
power men have learned to define power
slightly differently feeling obligated
to earn money as somebody else spends
what we die sooner and it's not a patch
it's a big a little tongue-in-cheek
there but it's also there's a fair
amount of truth to that as we saw as we
saw as we sort of looked at look at the
different decisions that men and women
have learned to make so when we've
looked at men so if we go out here to
take a cab back to our offices
afterwards today the chances are very
good that the cab driver will be what a
male and asked that cab driver how many
hours per week he works on average it
will be between 65 and 70 ask that cab
driver the next question would you
choose to work this number of hours per
week you'll just about be thrown out of
the cab then ask the cab driver the
question why do you work this number of
hours per week and the cab driver will
usually tell you some version of the
following I'm working this number of
hours per week so my children don't have
to work this number of hours per week so
my children can go to college so my
children could have advantages that I
don't have so my wife can take care of
the children so that my wife could have
food on the table and the mortgage
payment made the mistake I think that we
made in the last 30 years was assuming
that people who had money had power that
people had money as a result of
privilege and what I began to understand
as I did the research for why men are
and more was that people had money
because they sort of spit oftentimes
made sacrifices to get the power of pay
so I began to start seeing what I call
the pay paradox and the pay paradox was
basically that men earn money therefore
men have more power and men earned money
therefore men have less power and women
earn less money therefore women have
less power women earn less money
therefore women have more power because
in the process of earning less money
oftentimes the money that was earned was
less because there was a greater amount
of fulfillment in the occupational
choice the greater the amount of
fulfillment the greater the supply and
the greater amount of fulfillment often
the less the demand so teachers don't
get paid as much as we often say they
should because more people would
to be a teacher that or a librarian then
then more people enjoy reading books
than smelling garbage so we have to pay
our garbage collector more even if the
garbage collector isn't as well educated
then we have to pay the librarian or the
teacher because the librarian or the
teacher the great majority of people
prefer being a librarian or teacher
therefore that increases the supply in
relation to the demand basically I would
began to see that it was it's simpler
solution for us to blame men about the
pay gap than it is to engineer our own
bridge to higher pay and yet when people
do engineer their own bridge to higher
pay they women today out-earn men when
all those things are controlled for and
you will see statistic after statistic
that will appear to disprove this you
will see that male doctors earn more
than female doctors and you'll say ah
that Warren Farrell guy he was wrong and
yet if you look more carefully you'll
see that the male doctors are more
likely to be cardiac surgeons and the
female doctors are more likely to be
psychiatrist and then as you look more
closely you say I got chicken warned the
cardiac surgeons who are male out-earned
the cardiac surgeons that are female is
that true yes it's true but when you
look more closely the cardiac surgeons
that are male are more likely to work
more hours per week as cardiac surgeons
than the cardiac surgeons are female and
then you say I'll control for the hours
you control for the hours and you say
the male's still out or in those those
cardiac surgeons still out or in the
female maybe only by a percent or so but
proves you're wrong Warren then you and
you control for private practice the
male cardiac surgeons are more likely to
be in private practice the female
primary cardiac surgeons are more likely
to work for a government agency or some
type of public practice or an HMO or
something along those lines and as you
control for all of those variables
that's when the women out earn the men
and the for me the importance of this
research and then what intrigued me
about is I have two daughters 117 and
118 they're entering the workplace I
want them to I want them to understand
take responsibility for their choices I
want them to be able to make to know
where and how to make
choices that are productive for them and
in their lives and be able to not walk
around feel like angry at the world that
men have basically figured out a system
to get themselves to be paid more at the
expense of women if that exists at even
the one half of one percent level we
have to change that if that exists it
means we have a contempt for women that
needs to be changed but fortunately it
doesn't exist and as I started doing the
research of this I became very pleased
that the world was a little bit fairer
that I thought it was when I started out
in this work thanks very much Thank You
Warren we have time for questions I'll
let you call on people please wait for a
microphone to come around so everybody
can hear your question including on the
web broadcast I do questions and answers
also a little bit differently than most
people do I believe that there's more
resources in this room than than me and
so I'm opened tooth lsq as you stand up
and say ask a question to touch you know
that I'm okay with a comment as well as
a question I'd like you to say your name
so i can speak with you as a person
rather than as an object to a lecturer
or luxury to object and so and then i
will ask usually one or two other people
to comment on that perspective and then
i will add my own perspective as well so
that we turn this into sort of a
recognition that we all have
perspectives of views that are worth
hearing here so is there anybody that
would like to start out yes so your name
you stand up Jim my name is hi Jay hi my
name is June myers and i'm not sure what
the plural of this is even though i'm
female but what what do you think would
happen if men could bear children if men
had uterus are you to Rye what would
then how would this impact your data I
mean because we can't choose to adopt
now yes I think these choices will
probably archetypal II made a long time
ago
and you know the hunter-gatherer them
homemaker so if men could really have
children how would that impact your yes
you is this could June's question is if
men could have children how would that
impact these findings anybody have any
thoughts on that any feelings about it
yes aside from adoption yes say your
name my name is Brad and I really
enjoyed your myth of male power book
thank you brandy that I was just
thinking about your interview you did
with Ken Wilber sorry Jane I mean it's a
bread will you I'm asking for comments
on Jews point and then I'll come to a
new point okay so your right up after
June but right now comments on June's
point if men could have children how
would things be different physically
June you want them to answer oh oh I see
physically have children say your name
all right my name is Patrick and if men
had children and the children would
survive men would have to have a
completely different set of feelings yes
I saw anybody different set of feelings
feeling similar to the ones that women
have which are evolutions way in my
opinion to make sure that children
survival a certain portion so that so
that the result I think would be that
basically men would be pursuing
strategies similar to those of women and
I believe that evil evolutionarily two
different paths have made sense to the
two different sexes and those feelings
and emotions that having children
necessarily requires if those children
are going to survive very good inside
and very important inside anybody else
would I take it on before I give a
perspective on Kathleen is it is a
Catherine sorry I your name Katherine
Katherine unless you stand oh sure well
I think that June's question raises an
interesting point which is sort of what
I'm debating about your
you're the structure that you've built
in your book which is a lot of these
choices aren't necessarily choices that
people can make that women or men can
make that you know to work longer hours
or to have higher education or to be in
a more scientific field is not
necessarily a choice that any given
woman could make and I think that the I
may have seen so many studies that women
are working bad shifts and working in
low-skilled industries not making a lot
of money it's it seems to me that yes in
an ideal world it would be great if the
man or the woman could choose to be the
breadwinner but I just wonder how much
of that is the reality yes good okay
excellent points 1 more comment than I
have my question come into a singer
named Paul shore I hope I don't see
mean-spirited by essentially demolishing
the question that was raised but if men
could have children then maybe they'd
have to be fertilized by women otherwise
there couldn't be any genetic
recombination with each new generation
and therefore each sex would be
hermaphroditic and therefore both sexes
would be the same men would be women and
women would be men so there would be no
sex differences to account for there
would be only one sex in the human in
the human species very fascinating guys
okay great yes okay but let's let's work
with sort of the spirit of that question
if I may june that's a that's a very
good answer in a thoughtful answered by
the way let's take it down to sort of
the practicality of let's say men were
raising children more frequently than
they are as opposed to having them which
gets us into all the biological
dimensions that but also I'll work with
that in just a moment but for a moment
let me say that it is true that the
probably what you're saying about the
field the the the energy of men and
women has become different in part
because children needed for women that
type of nurturing in that connection and
let me spend a minute on that before i
get into the the raising of children
issue one of the dilemmas that we have
is that men have learned to love the
family by being away from the love of
their family that his men have learned
to love the family by being at work
and as men are at work we developed
characteristics that are functional for
the workplace that are often
dysfunctional for loving our family so
for example a good CEO has to pay very
careful attention as someone is talking
to him or her about what about is this
the right market is this where can this
be place is this the right person for
Tabata to buy from and a good CEO
listening to a sales presentation is
going to be having to do 30 or 40
variables being juggled in his or her
mind now if I am that CEO and I come
home and junior or my wife and I
listened and you're talking to me and
I'm juggling 30 variables in my mind as
you're talking to me you don't feel very
loved you don't feel very heard the
emotional what I need to do is a as a
person who loves you it worried if I
loved you my new you yes ray would be
too emotionally completely engage with
your feelings your fears your hopes and
and and your words as you're speaking
them that is what women are able to do
so women being with children tend to be
trained to do that more frequently
whether that's biologically inherited or
not is another issue but the vet but the
so that's sort of the biology of it but
the socialization of it and the outcome
for children is sustaining I make quick
references before that children raised
by single fathers do better in 26
different areas of measurement than
children raised by single mothers that
is the just like many women who work in
the workplace add qualities to the
workplace that the workplace would not
have that lead to women being so much
safer in the workplace than they then
men are so for example in the Marines
400 people have died what's the
percentage of men that have died in the
Marines and women that are died of
Marines 100% men 400 men 400-plus men
have died zero women so for every single
person in the Air Force who has died has
been what a meal every single one only
one person in the Navy that has died in
the war in Iraq
Ben has been a woman this is all within
the framework of the War of the rock my
point is there that women can sometimes
people who are entrained in a certain
area can enter into in this case a
hazardous occupation and treat the
occupation in a way that produces
different outcomes men raising children
do extremely well in areas we would be
shocked to find or the case so children
the more contact a child has with his
father or her father the more likely
that child is to be empathetic now think
about that normally we say empathy is
from the woman to the child are women
more empathetic than men my personal
opinion yes but empathy does not create
empathy it turns out that good boundary
enforcement is more likely to force the
child to think of somebody else's needs
besides the child's needs and the child
is forced by the consequences of good
boundary enforcement to think of
somebody else besides himself or herself
so practically speaking what June's
question opens us to is a world where
there's a lot of potential encouragement
for women to be entering the workplace
at high focus levels and contributing
positively to that and men to be
entering the home market at the home
place and raising children but we still
aren't training our daughters to do this
so for example when I go to mo steady
party and I walk into that party and
there's a single woman I overhear the
hosts a over the way that guy over there
is he's in law school and he's going to
really be right at the top of his class
that person's working in a law firm that
person is doing working for the
government at this level that person is
working and as a surgeon at doing this
and she's given all the human doing
characteristics of men not the human
being characteristics of men I don't
hear very many hosts saying to a woman
by the way notice that fellow over there
he's asking a woman questions and he's
paying attention to her answers
and he's not pretending to know more or
having already known the answer and
notice that he's not talking with the
most attractive woman at the party he's
talking with an average looking moon to
the party and notice that as he's
talking with her he's not womanizing
with his eyes the more attractive women
that's the type of man who's showing
personality characteristics that
suggests that he would be very able to
support you to be the type of top career
woman that you might want to be and if a
woman wants to have it all she needs to
be re socialized to value those
characteristics and men so that she
selects for those men and doesn't wait
for that man to select her that she's
willing to take him out pay for him
because that would symbolize the type of
man who's open to being supported
economically by a woman but most women
when they contemplate supporting a man
economically lose respect for the man
and they back away from it even if they
aren't paid for in the first date they
start of sort of start shrinking but
that but as probably a combination of
biological a socialization but it really
is is we can't we can't separate biology
from socialization if you and I were
married and you were our daughter and we
and you had a and we started seeing you
going out with a couple of doctors and
lawyers and then you were going but you
had a really strong interest in this
artist who is really not going to be
likely to make any much of a living at
all and so we encourage you to sort of
we made things a little bit easier for
you to be with the doctor and the lawyer
less easy for you to be with the artist
and your girlfriend started saying what
about that doctor and lawyer and all
that reinforced it those are all
socialization forces that I'm talking
about but now you make the choice let's
say the doctor you have children and
what type of choice is that it's a
biological choice the socialization
pressures you in two biological choice I
mean choices that create biological
outcomes your children and so there are
children that you have from that
socialization pressure become the
children of the the doctor the lawyer
not the artist and so it and so when
people argue is it biology or is it
nature is it nurturing nature my answer
is
yes it's both it's overlapping it's not
able to be separated so does all that
makes sense in terms of so what this
book to me what women are and more opens
us up to is options for our daughters to
have it all but not to have it all by
marrying men who are superstars like
when they want to be superstars if
you're a super stiff you want to be a
superstar woman marry a man who will
support you if you want children it's
fine for a superstar woman to marry a
superstar man if there's no desire for
children but not if there is and go okay
say your name oh I'm sorry wait a minute
I skip Brad and I'll come to yourself
Fred it is it Brad he said it's Brad Oh
saw war it was um I was going to get
into this between the ho and the plow
which it be too complicated to get into
but oh but thanks for fur going back to
me but okay Satan say your name hi I'm
Christina Missy um sort of building off
what you were last saying if you read
any take an anthropology class of Io
anthropology class they'll say you know
women tend to value achievement in men
men tend to value other things it in and
so I'm sorry beauty and youth you didn't
use exactly and so if you I'm wondering
if you think that there is still some
inequity and while you're talking about
and that there might be greater
trade-offs for a woman if they adopt the
the 25 ways to increase their pay that
there's another side of it that a woman
might not be able to find a very high
achieving woman would find it more
difficult to find a man that would take
the more traditional supporting role and
so there's there's greater risk that
there's a greater trade off in trying to
earn more money because they'll be less
likely to find supportive spouse or
something like that in a man would very
good question anybody have any thoughts
on Christina's question and then I'll
give my perspective on it okay that
question is so important that I asked
that question in almost every radio show
that I've been on for the
10 years which is a lot of radio shows
and I get you every woman in this room
will be very happy to hear the answer to
this I get about 10 women I'm sorry
about 10 men calling me saying that they
would love to be able to be supported by
a woman and they'd be happy to be fully
involved with the children do the
cooking do the cleaning or if there's
enough money hire the cleaning to be
done we'll figure out where she's moving
to move where she where the job requires
her to move to for each woman who calls
in saying I'm very open to supporting a
man economically who works out of the
home who may or may not raise money but
who takes care of all the things that
traditional women do as of this point in
history it's very clear to me that the
that actually men are more willing to
make that adaptation than women are
women get a great deal of pressure where
they when they start going out with men
who earn less they they get pressure
from their parents they get pressure
from women friends they get pressure
from the stuffed inside of themselves
that says am I look I've al Ewing myself
too little bit so thee but the the big
caveat with men is this a man will not
feel comfortable doing that if he's
picking up body language from the woman
that suggests that she really does not
respect him for doing that men are
prisoners of female approval and respect
if women said we want men to go around
walking on on their hands men would
begin to have contests about walking on
their hands and then they and then they
start jumping on one hand to show that
they're better than the men that walked
on one hands and they had marathons for
how far they could walk so that one of
the things I find out that it's true
about men is if a man says if a woman
says sweetie I really value what you
contribute to your children but at the
next party that man is notices that his
wife is eyeing a man who's a Nobel Prize
winner or a CEO or very high achieving
and her eyes are sort of dilating in
ways that suggests that she's interested
in him he begins to lose become insecure
and the woman says it's not that I want
a successful man i just don't want an
insecure man like my husband and the
whole cycle starts and the end it
deteriorate so a lot of if a woman is
interested in choosing a man like that a
lot of internal work needs to be done
about am I really okay with that now men
have the same problem in Reverse a man
can say to a woman but it's not on the
issue on this issue the my can say to a
man a man says to me yeah Warren I want
a woman who's warm and tender and loving
and caring and has a good sense of humor
and his fare and his kind and I just
can't find a woman out there like that
and I say oh I have a woman who's
exactly like that she does happen to be
300 pounds in 75 years of age and he
suddenly goes well like wasn't thinking
of that so men's Achilles heel is in the
beauty in the youth area just like
women's Achilles heel is in the in that
type of selection in that area does that
all make sense so so if it doesn't just
challenge me okay okay great okay fine
anybody else have any thoughts oh yes
right in the back say your name and can
you stand up please my name is Shawna
gamache and this is Sean that's Shauna
Shauna right I'm just curious as someone
who's maybe of the younger generation
here and an old person like me no no and
as someone whose husbands actually
already moved three times for me for
work I'm just curious what kind of
changes you are seeing with the younger
generation where you see this trend
going with you know the emergence of
such factors as the sensitive man and
also the opening of these fields that
you're talking about like everything
from the Marines to the financial sector
for women I'm where you see this going
yes well there's yes first of all
anybody else have any thoughts of your
all many of you are younger than I am
and so what are your experiences with
people your age another old man David ok
say it I know I know you David said I
know your first name is David oh baby
yeah well I just wanted you been on the
cutting edge of this now for a number of
years enriched Dorothy which is that
China Shana I do feel you are making a
dent or are these ideas making it dental
if so how much and is there any chance
for any general acceptance of these
unusual ideas but accepted by many
people who understand you what you're
saying well thank you anybody else on
whether things are changing for younger
people and I will be happy to I'll get
yes Peter no I'm losing I think it's
fine horses career microphone Peter you
take the microphone yeah I just want to
say I've had about I'm 65 I learn about
five careers I've lost count I including
army research university and stuff like
that and I've lived in four continents
oh and we're being globalized and this
is happening and what people need to do
is start from a young age making choices
both men and women and have the courage
to make a choice and make a decision
that's just one of you in that person's
right thank you your book right being
cool maybe the paradox but it like that
maybe call it the paper that a paradox
yeah hey that was the first name of the
book yeah right that's best
and I mean we are men with stuck in
these careers or were stuck in these
community 30 years because we thought we
had to earn more money yes but you know
every single man just has to make a
choice and you know but his life first
which is what a women apparently do yes
good thank you Peter okay Shauna the
good news and the bad news okay the
things that I see changing are clearly
women are far more desirous of making
money women are clearly saying an
understanding that they need to take
responsibility for the possibility that
they are going to be earning their their
own income during their during the
course of their life that's what is
that's what's changing and that's
wonderful and that's good what is not
changing and is creating some deeper
problems that almost anyone has looked
at what is not changing is that when
women marry and I ask women a little bit
let's check this out here in the
audience to make sure I'm right about
this just ask you to close everybody
here just close your eyes for a moment
and visualize your wedding day if you're
from California you can choose any
number of your wedding days there if you
if you've had more than one wedding just
choose the maybe choose your first
marriage and imagine your spouse on your
wedding day now imagine me coming up to
you and saying tell me what's right
what's true for you do you believe that
your husband or your wife will earn
consistently more than you during your
lifetime together do you believe yours
and this is the belief you had on your
wedding day makes no difference what
actually happened but the belief on your
wedding day was your best prediction
that your spouse to be would earn more
or less than you during your years
together I'll ask you to open your eyes
if your women and you end you have been
married raise your hand about whether
you believed on your wedding day that
your partner would probably make as much
or more than you raise your hand if you
believe in your wedding day that your
partner we are in less than you okay so
about an eighty-five percent of the
people have been married
men raise your hand if you believe that
you would earn more as much or more than
your wife when you're on your wedding
day raise your hand if you believed you
would earn less than your wife on your
wedding day so yes so only two men in
the room believed that they would earn
less than their wife so the and that's
that hasn't that part Shana has not
changed very much when and the problem
that that creates is that we have women
earning more and more but oftentimes
marrying men who are not earning as much
or are expected to earn as much but in
fact do not do not end up earning as
much and then there is a real problem
that occurs usually the women expect who
expects the man to be earning more who
ends up becoming downsized while she
becomes upsize starts becoming
dissatisfied internally and that tends
to lead to divorces and so we we've
changed the society without changing the
expectations of women or men about who
is eligible for love we have a lot of
women if we ask that question slightly
differently we get a very different
answer if I said how many women have men
friends or are living with men who are
earning less you'd see a large number of
female hands go up how many women are
currently living with or women for her
or friends with men who are earning less
a much higher percentage of female hands
go up but when it comes to marriage
those women don't usually get married to
those men unless they believe the men
will be earning as much or more so in
those types of cohabitation or
boyfriend/girlfriend relationships
there's a break off and men know
therefore there will beat the so the
message to men is there will be no love
unless there's what there'll be no love
unless there's money and as long as men
know that then men or feel that way they
don't know it but they feel that way as
long as been feel that way men will take
an attitude toward money
will be different than the female
attitude towards money it will be very
similar the female attitude toward
weight and toward looks and toward youth
where women know that there's no real
love unless there's a reasonable weight
reasonable looks and reasonable amount
of youth and both all sad things
probably both genetically selected for
but this is still the what's changing
and what isn't to answer shot his
question does that respond to your
question Charlotte thank you sure say
your name sharon lee drum having not
read your book i can only guess and how
you did this analysis but I sort of take
issue with some of the fundamental
statistical correlations that you're
trying to make or conclusions that
you're trying to to draw from these
because I don't know if you've
controlled for certain things like
ambition or things like that but it
seems like a woman who fits sort of all
your criteria of being the cardiac
surgeon who's willing to work as many
hours as the male may have some other
characteristics that you're not
controlling for and so I kind of find it
all disturbing that you're trying to
wipe away that entire argument that
women who have the same qualifications
are in fact making or you're wiping away
the argument that women who have all the
same characteristics and do the same
exact job don't make a percentage of
what a man would work or a man would
make so I maybe you can just absolutely
clarify that a little bit this was there
anybody that has any thoughts on that
before I give my perspective on that yes
Catherine Catherine has interviewed me
recently and has read my book so I'd be
interested to hear what you say well I
on a similar point I'm also was
surprised that when you're looking at
the situation that you mentioned earlier
nursery school teachers that the small
percentage of men in that field leads to
the conclusion that men are
discriminated against and yet when you
look at investment bankers and you say
there's a small percentage of women why
doesn't that also lead to the conclusion
that women are discriminated against in
that field good very good ok I take I'll
take Shawn Lee's question first and then
and then segue into yours Katherine
the no one can control for all 25 of
these variables so I did the best I
could to sort of look it's sort of the
different impacts of them but among the
variables that you are very perceptive
enough to sort of put your fingers on is
the the question about goals and
ambitions of the person men and women to
begin with and that is one of the 25
differences that contributes to higher
or lower pay than women women are much
more likely both who own their own
businesses and also women at every age
group when the Harris and Gallup polls I
ask them questions and in every
industrialized country which is where we
have good polls from all have different
goals than men do in the workplace and
much much higher percentage of women
want fulfillment and they want
flexibility usually a question that's
not asked but only when it's asked does
it occur is safety they don't also want
to take risks a great deal in their work
and I just reaffirmed all this with an
American Management Association survey
which I asked all these questions about
the 25 ways in that survey and all these
things turned out to be true among
managers as of a few weeks ago who were
asked these questions so that MIT
predominantly women wants fulfillment
they want flexibility for family
purposes they want safety they want our
they want to work but they don't usually
want to work on average they don't want
to work more than 35 to 40 hours a week
pay is important to them but it's not
the primary primary importance of not of
primary importance even women who own
their own businesses only twenty-seven
percent say pay is a primary reason that
they own their own business whereas men
it's over forty percent saying the same
thing so that's that's sort of like the
larger picture of the differences in the
goals area the on your question
Katherine in terms of why do I conclude
that women men are nursery school
teachers at a such a small percentage
and that implies discrimination and
women are bank
but investment bankers at a small
percentage and that does not imply
discrimination the only way you can
evaluate discrimination is to look
carefully at people percentages of
applicants what happens to those
applicants when they apply and also are
there people that fear going into a
field because they've gotten
communication ahead of time that those
that they are going to be discriminated
against and when men men very few men
apply to be nursery school teachers
because men sort of sense there that
they're not going to be accepted in that
area but the closest thing you can come
to it in large numbers is out men who do
have elementary education backgrounds
and apply to be elementary education
teachers in first grade's first through
third and there we have a lot of men
saying that there that they cannot that
they do not get that they apply for
those positions but they are not
accepted interestingly enough that I had
together only anecdotal evidence on that
there's not a single study done by any
education institution that I could come
up with that that even asked schools
what is the percentage of male versus
female applications it's just that all
over the country when I talk about these
issues men call me and say I hadn't got
an elementary education degree one of
them quit from being a very top level
government employee because everybody
said that he was a great teacher he had
raised his own children so he quit a job
gave a pension a risked his wife's
disapproval became a teacher got an
elementary school education called me on
the radio and said every single man that
graduated with me could not get a job I
couldn't get a job everybody thinks I'm
gifted as a as a teacher but every
single woman in my class got a job so
it's only data like that that I that I
asked the society to look more carefully
at that issue does that answer your
question Katherine anything that I
haven't answered about it
okay and check with me at lunch if it's
been wonderful talking with you and feel
free to sort of continue this dialogue
as we enjoyed each other for lunch
thanks for your thoughtful questions
thank you very much Warren we do have
copies of why men earn more outside and
we invite you to get one and I'm sure
Warren would be glad to sign them and
we'll be upstairs for lunch and I remind
you that we will have this forum
available on our website wwk org if you
want to go back and check any of the
numbers and percentages or anything
Thank You Warren Farrell is author of
the myth of male power and why men are
the way they are his latest why men
earned more is published by amacom books
on the web at Emma com books or